raise your standards
if you want to make a massive leap
forward in your business or your life it
starts with raising your standards and
clearly identifying what it is that you
will no longer stand for entrepreneurs
come to me and they complain that
people aren't paying them the prices
they want they're working with less than
ideal clients they don't work for
business they cause a lot of problems
and fine like that's great that you're
working with these crappy clients but
you agreed to that
you took those guys on that's not on
them being a crappy client that's on you
for not having good enough standards in
your business
raise your standards
i just got a document from a supplier
that i'm working with they want to
represent me they want to showcase my
business try to bring in a few new deals
and the document that came back was so
crappy it was a one-page overview about
who i was that they wanted to show
potential partners
and i was thinking are you kidding me
this is what you're going to send out
this is how you're going to be
presenting me
the content was okay the the the quality
of the presentation was terrible
and i sent it back so this is not
acceptable and i redesigned it myself
because i have standards
you need to have standards in your
business as well
any practical advice tip guidance
support that i give you is useless
if you don't have standards
raise your standards i'm launching a new
website
and my designer wants to kill me
because we're making so many great
changes and i'm so particular about what
i want
and it has to be high quality and he's
like most people are never going to
notice it
and that's fine
i don't care i'm not doing it for them
or doing it for me because this is what
i believe in
even if nobody notices that that thing
is one pixel off i'm going to notice it
and it's not to my standards so it has
to get better
everything in the business has to get
better has to be higher quality has to
be held to a higher standard so if you
want to get more success if you want to
reach for higher stars if you want to
really grow your business
or make a big change in your life you
start with raising your standards and i
know it's hard
it's really hard because that's that's
changing one of your beliefs
right we're changing one of the things
that we fundamentally believe in
ourselves
it's scary stepping outside and doing
something new and changing how we think
and oftentimes the environment you have
around you is keeping you down your
friends your family the people you hang
out with the resources you surround
yourself with the environment that
you're in keeping is keeping you down
it's holding you back
so you have to set new patterns get a
new environment hang out with people who
build you up
increase the standard of who you hang
out with
this applies to everything it's not just
your business it's everything
if you're in a relationship and you're
not being treated well you're not being
treated to the standard that you deserve
then that's not the relationship for you
you have to have the confidence
to believe in yourself
and know that you deserve better
if you don't believe in yourself
nobody's gonna believe in you and you're
gonna stay with these crappy clients who
don't pay you who complain and you're
never going to reach your potential
so start today
raise your standards and believe that
you can do it
you guys like this video please give it
a thumbs up below it makes you do more
for you and i want to hear what you have
to think if this video impacted you if
it touched you please leave it in the
comment section below i read the
comments every morning that really makes
my day when they come in so thank you so
much if you have a question too leave it
below i'll make a video response thank
you guys so much i'll see you soon